cyberpunk 2077 has several different
endgame missions
and possible endings accessing them
depends on some of the choices you make
throughout the game
and which characters you choose to help
but there's also another
secret ending one that you might not
ever uncover if you don't know how to
find it
here's everything you need to know to
access the secret ending which requires
some specific dialogue choices during
the chip and in side mission
of course be warned there will be
cyberpunk spoilers so continue at your
own risk
to access the secret ending continue
through the main story until you finish
the tapeworm quest that'll give you
access to a new side mission
called chip and in work your way through
that quest until you get to the end
where you'll have a conversation with
johnny silverhand in an oil field about
his life
you'll need to make specific dialogue
decisions during this conversation to
unlock the ending just follow through
the choices you see on screen
so that's how it is
nothing here at all
what did you expect headstone flag and
flowers
yeah i i don't know
a marker something anything
we'll figure something out
better now
a bit but let's say it was my real grave
what would you write here lies johnny's
silver hand
the guy who saved my life
v you don't know how much i want that to
be
true
listen i realize i [ __ ] up a lot of
things
[Music]
either let down or used every last
person who gave me their trust
blind selfish bastard that i was
but i've managed one thing for now not
to [ __ ] this up
what we have
no johnny you [ __ ] that up too you
used me
lied to me i can't trust you at all
[Music]
is it too late to ask for a second
chance
what do you want from me
most people i thought were my friends
they couldn't even stand to be in the
same room with me
you're [ __ ] closest to me by a long
shot
there 24 7.
and yet you don't seem to hate my living
guts
at least so it seemed till now
okay but as second chances go
this is your last i refuse to be that
naive
i'll try damn tired
johnny silverhand relentless rocker boy
who never gives up
v first amongst suckers
[Music]
you're a real dick wipe at first
you sort of deserved it remember waking
up at victor's not knowing about me
i'm seeing things i'm scared
then moaning at misties about how you
didn't want to die
remember you whining for smokes in the
middle of night complaining about not
being able to kill me
never thought we'd make it this far
when you said you let your friends down
did you mean rogue
rogue alt kerry santiago
not always lost yet at least with rogue
can't pretend nothing's changed over 50
years
can't just insert myself into our life
smasher biz really got to her you can't
leave it like this
i don't think might be right she was
acting weird
you oughta talk to her you know did
promise her i'd take her to the movies
long long ago good idea
call her for me ask if she's free some
night
thing is you'd have to surrender control
again
yeah i'll call her
okay let's delta nothing to see here
after all worth coming out all the same
absolutely thanks fee
of all the heads i could have popped up
in hella glad it was yours
finishing chipping in will unlock
another mission called blistering love
you'll need to finish that one too don't
worry your choices there won't matter
you have to finish this mission
to unlock the right ending choices
though now go to the point of no return
the main story mission nocturne op55n1
after your conversation with hanako
arasaka you'll wind up at vixx
go through the dialogue and misty will
take you up to the roof to make your
decision about how to approach the end
game
during this conversation first pick the
option to let johnny and rogue raid
arasaka tower
after that just wait you'll need to let
the game sit without saying anything
for around four to five minutes kind of
tough deciding which of your friends get
to die
isn't it good news is you got this one
tomb who's already dead
and he'd be honored to join you on a
wild suicide run
johnny will then give you another option
going to arasaka tower alone with just
johnny and no backup
unlocks the don't fear the reaper
endgame mission it's one of cyberpunk
2077's toughest challenges and you'll
want to get v's level and gear as high
as you can before you attempt it if you
die during this end game mission
cyberpunk will cut to the credits so you
have to make it all the way to mikoshi
in one attempt we've got a ton of
cyberpunk 2077 coverage so be sure to
check out gamespot.com for more
if i gotta die rather fall into my grave
gun in hand and on fire and not drag
anyone down with me
huh you just discovered what it takes to
become a legend
grab your eye let's mobilize
[Music]
you